again with the sun show doesn't think it
can open an episode without looking at
the sky and that's the second time this
fetish has caused me eyeball pain
writers include this this and this just
in case we confused it with japan
missouri we are left to wonder
who will save us now
[Music]
i will vanity everyone has black
umbrellas at a funeral cliche never get
invited show up anyway justifying
funeral crashing i may have completely
forgotten how to write in cursive but i
know most of these are just random
squiggles shame on you dark blood
pretending to take notes didn't mean to
offend nuance of human conversation
difficult for me well omniman isn't
human so the nuance is moot robot
you know for a bunch of computer code
you run a main superhero team are there
no other robots in this world has this
name never been an issue when robot just
happens to be standing next to another
robot or is robot a surname and cecil is
just one of those people also that's
robotist this flower over here looks
very similar to this flower over here a
little too similar hey he could run fast
okay it's not exactly one of your
premier super powers nolan is a dick to
speedsters i was thinking finals are
coming up and we're both in miss
walker's global issues class study dates
while i do believe these books do
contain references to bio and math i
find it hard to accept that any
publisher worth their salt would use
titles this general i knew there was a
reason you skipped the funeral skipping
a funeral to have sex with duplicate
wait is that actually a sid
hold on what's that
okay so i was just informed that this is
percent without a doubt no questions
asked a sin
i actually think this joke is pretty
hilarious but geometry despite your name
i believe you underestimate yourself
invincible but mark said nothing about
doubting himself he said he couldn't
join because his dad wanted to handle
training him and his mom didn't want him
to miss any more school and then the
director said have him bounce his pecs
that will make him look like even more
of an apple wait what somebody ought to
teach you some [ __ ]
despite being surrounded by super
individuals rex chode underestimates
someone named monster girl come on man
read the room also rex survives this we
find out monster girl is wary of
transforming often since every time she
does she gets a little younger so why is
she wasting a change on [ __ ] rexplode
invincible hit that little girl show
thinks that someone who just witnessed
that fight between rex and monster girl
is really going to try and cancel
invincible over this i'm sure your junk
is awesome even with the power dynamic
reversed this still feels wrong welcome
to the guardians of the globe monster
girl along with rex splode what exactly
is rex splode bringing to the table
you're telling me that out of the 20 or
so superheroes that didn't make it none
of them were more qualified than rex
because i do not believe you rex cheated
on me with duplicate all three of her
whoa envy
and now lust this show is full of a lot
of actual sins so i'm sure no one will
complain about our video this time
around
as soon as the forensic investigation
has concluded we'll be moving into the
guardian's headquarters not a single one
of these numbskulls thinks it might be a
bad idea to set up shop at the scene of
the former guardian's unsolved murder
it's like they say die a hero or live
long enough to see yourself become an
eco villain go out the back way setting
aside the little detail of the stairs
leading directly to the front door why
is this even necessary unless amber for
some reason hates dating guys with
friends william's presence should have
absolutely no impact on her perception
of mark well then the whole concept of
personal privacy or me time
that's out the window facebook's user
agreement doc seismic isn't burned
seared or lightly browned in any way
despite being incredibly close to lava
also there is no lava close to the
surface of mount rushmore invincible
completes this repair without a proper
mortar mix he doesn't even consider a
bonding agent that's just shoddy
craftsmanship those aren't clothes
gloves have fingers they're more uh
earthquake bracelets while these are
essentially bracelets invincible doesn't
acknowledge the existence of fingerless
gloves also mocking this dangerous
technology that has probably already
killed several people also also taking
time for these not so clever quips when
the success of your date depends upon
you dealing with this situation quickly
and efficiently i thought your doctor
was in seismology undergrad in sociology
and women's studies i had a minor in
african dance holy woke villain darkwing
i mean i don't know if i should [ __ ] him
or fight him random tourists randomly
being put into random jeopardy are
random show creates false tension by
expecting us to believe that this man
will die a horrible death joe also
assumes i will care if this man dies a
horrible death and i do not wow that guy
is toast oh i see so like none of these
sound good huh pun shaming you left a
girl in your room while you flew off to
deal with a crisis good yeah because
telling amber you forgot you had
something to do and you can meet up
later so then she could go back home or
wherever and accomplish other things and
possibly hold on to some dignity would
just be silly one last piece of fatherly
advice okay
you might want to change as should you
nolan i'm assuming both mark and debbie
would have people that don't know nolan
his omniman over to the house so why
would he ever be just wandering around
the downstairs with his omni-man showing
i sold a house today that had a double
homicide i told them lightning never
strikes twice technically it did strike
twice just in rapid succession thursday
getting this excited about chicken pot
pie go ahead wrote me in with this
cliffhanger reveal that robot was
actually behind the mahler twin escape
because otherwise i had no intention
whatsoever to watch any more episodes of
this very entertaining take on the
superhero genre escape from hell seek
justice for others to save own soul
show knows exactly what it feels like to
quit your job in sales blow all your
money on developing a terrible student
film and ultimately end up writing for
tv sins yeah maybe too soon in the
series to make this call but i don't
care nolan furrows his brow cliche
it is over between us kate nobody makes
me bleed my own blood
i fought the unimaginable look at where
we
started i know i don't deserve you eliza
but hear me out
that would be enough
robot i have a name it's dennis dennis
mccoy
hello
[Music]
you're terrified of me aren't you
i am not scared
how's it going in here
i brought snacks so many snacks so
little time
holy conflagration wow that guy is toast
this chick is toast